hey y'all it's andrew couch here i'm a
data scientist and today i'm going to be
reacting to ai and machine learning in
movies
our first movie is ex machina
do you know what the touring test is
yeah
i know what the turing test is
it's when a human interacts with a
computer
and if the human doesn't know they're
interacting with a computer
the test is passed
and what does the past tell us
that the computer has artificial
intelligence
are you building an ai
i've already built one
and over the next few days
you're going to be the human component
in the turing test holy [ __ ] yeah that's
right caleb you got it
because if that test is passed
you
are dead center of the greatest
scientific event in the history of man
if you've created a conscious machine
it's not the history of man
that's the history of gods
so uh in ex machina they're obviously
creating a machine uh and this machine
is an ai uh and how we test this is
we're trying to convince a human that
this machine is uh human
when in reality it's just a model or
whatever
so this is actually a pretty famous test
uh i guess among like career science and
people who are really kind of like
studying technology
that being said
for most data scientists on the
day-to-day uh you're not really gonna
experience a lot with like turing tests
and stuff like that although it's very
fancy and a nice little thought
experiments uh most of the time we're
actually working with like basic models
to do simple predictions
um there is a common thing with uh
people using ai and machine learning
interchangeably um for me i think
there's a little bit separate
differences so we have data science as
its entire i guess group and then we
have ai machine learning in data science
but
uh ai is machine learning but machine
learning is not aei
so machine learning we're always
thinking about is like basic models like
linear logistic regression uh you have
your you know your tree based models
like random forest and xg boost and
stuff like that
but what difference what differentiates
ai is
really working with like unstructured
data so when we're thinking about using
ai is for like uh text data uh sound uh
images and video
and
that really encompasses neural networks
so neural networks are mostly kind of
associated with ai
and not even just neural networks but uh
deep learning so deep learning is
essentially a neural network with a lot
of layers
generally i think we call deep learning
more than three layers but uh it's you
know there's not a set rule
so when we have a lot of deep learning
we generally say like ai and stuff like
that but uh for me uh i generally try to
keep it towards just machine learning uh
i think ai uh has some connotations of
like trying to sell something uh
especially uh
you know with these uh new tech
companies that they have this new ai
when in reality it's some type of like
you know uh bert model right uh from
google so
you know in general you'll hear uh
thrown around you hear ai and a lot of
like product presentations stuff like
that but i think most data scientists
don't really talk about saying like ai
they say machine learning or deep
learning
um this kind of addresses a lot of like
interesting quirks about
um data science so the touring test is
all about like how can we
kind of
reach the new milestone in machine
learning but there are definitely a lot
of discussions that are pretty good
thought experiments so uh i think that
kind of comes to mind especially like in
the past few years is the uh the baby in
the street with autonomous cars so like
tesla
one of the scenarios is like hey you see
a baby on the road
and a autonomous vehicle is driving does
the thomas vehicle uh swerve and avoid
the baby or
or does it kill the baby
um and this is a pretty good interest
like it's a good thought experiment
about hey how should we
uh uh program and develop uh
philosophical ideas into these models
but at the end of the day i think we
also have to think about how data
science is kind of a product oriented
uh disciple
or discipline uh so when we're trying to
create uh these products uh generally uh
we're trying to dealing with like who is
gonna be using these products and
generally who are people going to be
using these products such as autonomous
vehicles or people who want to buy the
car
uh so if you were if we were to create a
uh product that would kill the consumer
then no one would buy it
so you know just a common more
straightforward way to think about it is
hey
uh it would save the driver
and uh kill the baby in this made-up
scenario
because no one would want to drive a car
that would prioritize someone else over
themselves uh so that's just kind of a
little common thing uh that we hear a
lot and i think that's a pretty simple
way to view a lot of these um ethical
decision makings obviously i've kind of
uh
re-uh formatted the question into a way
more of a applied and not on the
philosophical but it is something that's
kind of interesting that uh kind of
makes me roll my eyes when i hear these
uh kind of debates but again it's not a
bad
thought experiment but it's something
that's not really uh used a lot in
applied data science that being said uh
ethics in data science is a huge issue
it's not really taught in
data science classes and most data
scientists haven't really taken an
ethics class on ethical uses of data
which is something that society as a
whole or at least academia needs to
address
okay next clip
so we need to break the ice
do you know what i mean by that yes
what do i mean overcome initial social
awkwardness
so let's have a conversation
okay
what would you like to have a
conversation about why don't we start
with you telling me something about
yourself what would you like to know
whatever comes into your head
well
you already know my name
and you can see that i'm a machine
would you like to know how old i am sure
i'm one
one what
one year or one day
when did you learn how to speak ava
i always knew how to speak
and that's strange
isn't it
why
because language is something that
people acquire
well
some people believe language exists from
birth and what is learned is the ability
to attach words and structure to latent
ability do you agree with that
i don't know
will you come back tomorrow caleb
so in this scene they're talking about
uh associating text with meaning um and
that's actually a common thing of how we
actually create these uh
ai or text models um
in the field of text or as the process
of language
we have two different distinctions nlp
and nlu so nlp is natural language
processing and it's all about making you
know models
and just like basic text analysis so
with models you know a common thing that
we do or a common starting place is a
model to predict ratings using imdb
review text right
for text analysis we have a bunch of
different
methods like topic modeling so getting
all this text and creating topics from
it uh we also have like sentiment
analysis so associating positive
negative sentiment to it and we also
have like just basic basic processing of
text data using bag of words or engrams
which are like a pairings of words uh
which uh as for nlu which is called
natural language understanding it's more
about the how word how models can
comprehend words and kind of have their
relationships paired with each other
um with nlu we do a lot like topic
summarization so
we have a model read an article and kind
of summarize it uh we also have like
question answer models so you know you
ask it
to say like where's uh when is my bill
do and i'll return an answer and also
text generation which is used a lot
obviously in these ai movies where this
uh
model is essentially receiving uh text
and
generating new text from it as like a
conversation
um what's actually interesting is that
language models or nlp and l and eu nlu
fields are
are growing and the technology is
advancing
by pretty fast rates
i had these two examples of basically
how we
can
combine words and kind of pair them up
to have like similar meanings uh summer
meetings between the words
and how these models actually do it
so
one of the main ways we do this by is by
using embeddings and embeddings are
basically compressing all these words
into these values and having them put
into a latent space or a kind of a
dimension
um and right here on the left is the
most basic um way it's called word to
vec uh embeddings and as you can see
what it's doing is it's associating
queen and king as they're closer to each
other than women and man
but as you can see queen and women are
close to each other uh queen and king
are close together because they're all
kind of about royalty and also about
gender uh we can see vice versa where
king and man and king and queen are
close together but if you notice queen
and man are very far away and kinked
women are far away
so that's a good way to basically
associate these synonymous words
together um but and now in these like
newer language models with like modern
ai
we usually use like neural network
embeddings
so on the right is an example of
tensorflow embeddings and right here
it's basically mapping up all these
points um in this case it's using
essentially the embedding values so
embedding values at the end of day are
just
numbers
with different dimensions
and they're doing basically which uh
using these embedding values we're
finding uh the nearest points next to a
specific word that's associated with
that embedding so in this case they're
finding the word important and find the
nearest uh words to it uh using the
embedding values and as you can see uh
we have like significant particular
essential vital all these words are uh
the closest to it the word important and
they're very synonymous with each other
so
we can see how these models are actually
pretty good at putting uh
almost uh like synonymous words together
which can then translate to like actual
understanding of these words even though
i have the preface is that these models
aren't really understanding the words
they're just kind of looking at their
associations together and uh pairing
them up to the
uh
to the distance to each other so the
distance and the relative usage of the
words are basically created using
embeddings that can also simulate as
being like uh understanding using
synonyms
uh but
it's a great uh uh movie about kind of
like these ethics of it and we're
getting a little bit closer but it's a
little too out there in the future for
what we have right now
okay our next movie is her
oh
hi
hi
how are you doing
i'm well
how's everything with you
pretty good actually
it's really nice to meet
you oh it's
nice to meet you too
oh what what do i call you do you have a
name
um
yes
samantha
where'd you get that name from i gave it
to myself actually
i'll come
because i like the sound of it
samantha
wait
when did you give it to yourself well
right when you asked me if i had a name
i thought yeah he's right i do need a
name but i wanted to pick a good one so
i read a book called how to name your
baby and out of 180 000 names that's the
one i like the best wait you read a
whole book in the second that i asked
you what your name was in 2 100th of a
second actually
wow
so do you know what i'm thinking right
now
well i take it from your tone that
you're challenging me
maybe because you're curious how i work
do you want to know how i work yeah
actually
how do you work
well basically i have intuition i mean
the dna of who i am is based on the
millions of personalities of all the
programmers who wrote me but what makes
me me
is my ability to grow through my
experiences so basically in every moment
i'm evolving
just like you
so in this movie or in this scene
they're kind of showing a a more uh
good uh a more good representation of
what we're kind of gonna see in the
future um obviously samantha is mostly a
virtual assistant like we what we have
right now which is like siri alexa and
cortana and what's actually very
interesting about her is that uh natural
speech is actually uh natural speech
processing is progressing very fast so
siri definitely sounds more like a human
every uh every year and uh language
models are evolving
so um it actually kind of plays a huge
role in the future of virtual assistants
and also how we interact with technology
uh for example like with virtual
assistants uh people were kind of
talking about how we should start saying
like please siri okay siri can you
please get my mail or my email and stuff
like that uh i know less demanding so we
can kind of teach people better manners
and how we can interact with each other
that being
said uh in the scene we talk uh they
talk about how uh samantha names herself
um
in general um that's actually pretty
straightforward uh when we generate new
words uh with a trend model uh we
generally just generate a random number
from that word which will generate like
a letter and then i'll kind of continue
generating random stuff with the most
probable letter after those words and
that can generate like a name
uh one thing that's pretty interesting
is that they talk about how
samantha or this virtual assistant was
built and just built by these uh
programmers and developers who will use
like other personalities which you can
associate with like text or text data
and conversations and yeah that's a
pretty uh straightforward way of how
people make all these language models
um additionally or lastly they talk
about how once she's released to a
a person uh then the model starts to
kind of adjust and learn a little bit
more
from that person's behavior and that's
ex that's extremely accurate that's how
a lot of models are being used today
so uh that itself is what's called is
transfer learning uh transforming is
basically the idea is that we can use
these models that were developed using
millions and billions of data and then
basically adding another layer to it and
letting that layer be adjusted to serve
our needs
so stuff like specific like computer
vision
i don't have a lot of images i don't
have like i don't even have it nvidia
gpu but google was able to create a lot
of models uh using all these images with
that are labeled and i can use google's
model freeze all the weights in the
coefficients from that model add another
layer and use that layer to basically
tune a model to whatever problem i have
so in this case they're just cutting off
the end of the model adding another
classifier to it which is in this case
is a support vector machine and using
that to make predictions so again i
think her is probably one of the most
accurate
uh ai machine learning movies for the
future and what we can see from so great
movie and a great clip
our next movie is 2001 a space odyssey
open the pod bay doors hal
i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that
what's the problem
i think you know what the problem is
just as well as i do what are you
talking about
this mission is too important for me to
allow you to jeopardize it
i don't know what you're talking about
hal
so this is a commonly referred uh scene
uh when we're thinking about the dangers
of machine learning right so how um and
just to give a little context of how um
how is ibm
uh if we increase the letters by one
uh for each uh letter and how it means
ibm and i think the general idea is like
can models go off on their own and
destroy the world
uh scenario is that models obviously are
trying to optimize some type of function
and one of the things that they're
talking about is hey we're gonna have a
model that or a model or ai that'll uh
reduce sickness in the world and how the
model decides to reduce sickness is
essentially to kill everyone um and this
is kind of not really sensical with how
we actually use models um
in the at the end of the day when we
create models it's just generating a
single output or like a probability or a
value
and most models are just good at just
doing one specific thing uh and in
general models are just never standalone
so
uh generally people will use a model to
uh predict something or to evaluate
something and then we're gonna actually
build infrastructure around it
uh
that being said there are a lot of
dangers with using models uh
specifically with unintended
consequences so one thing that we have
to deal with deal with is like uh what
type of data are we feeding into our
model and what about like negative
feedback loops so um one common example
is like chat bots uh when we when i
think uh ibm maybe or microsoft released
a chat bot uh they let people interact
with it and after like a few days the
chatbot was saying a lot of uh
derogatory and racist things and that is
a function of base basically how the
internet uh was interacting with these
chat bots uh they were saying curse
words to it
and then when they use that data to
input in the chat bot and then the chat
bot starts regurgitating what words were
inputted into it
so again it is something that people
need to be cognizant of specifically of
like the quality of data and how this
data is going to be interacted in our
systems that we're going to when we're
going to release a product but it's not
going to go off kill people uh in the
end of the day people are going to be
writing stuff
around the model and that can cause a
lot of problems but the model itself is
not just going to
go off on its own and do something else
and kill people
hopefully
but yeah good clip uh we'll go to the
next movie which is moneyball
[Music]
so using this equation in the upper left
right here i'm projecting that we need
to win at least 99 games in order to
make it to the postseason
we need to score at least 814 runs in
order to win those games and allow no
more than 645 runs
what's this
this is the code that i've written for
our year to year projections
this is building in all the intelligence
that we have to project players okay
it's about getting things down to one
number
using
stats the way we read them we'll find
value of players that nobody else can
see
[Music]
people are overlooked for a variety of
biased reasons and perceived flaws
age appearance personality
bill james and mathematics cut straight
through that
[Music]
okay so i i love moneyball i think
moneyball is like the most accurate way
of like that what data scientists
actually kind of do or data analysts
actually do um that being said obviously
it's off based off of a real story so
that's why it's a little bit more
accurate but as you see right here um
what he was saying or what joan hill's
character was saying was that it's uh
they're creating these metrics to
evaluate players and
right now in the modern day we do have
uh we're continuing on this process of
evaluating players based off their
statistics based off their data um and
maybe we're relying a little bit less on
you know visual and personality and
stuff like that although those do play a
huge role we have a little bit more
objective measures where we can use
these to rate players
sports data itself is actually very nice
for practicing your own data science
work it's highly available highly clean
and
obviously the sports data follows a lot
of distributions or common distributions
so uh we can do a lot of like
rudimentary statistics on it and uh get
a lot of value out of it
that being said uh it was kind of
interesting to see how there was a lot
of like value generations uh in the
scene
and that kind of follows a lot of this
modern way of data analysis or at least
like data forecasting uh which is using
a lot of bayesian inference
in bayesian inference we use things like
stan brms jags and bugs to basically uh
create projections of data um a common
forecasting thing with bayesian
inference is like presidential election
forecasts so
a very good video kind of shows what we
kind of look at
and also like how we kind of use our
data to do actual work and actual impact
into what we're trying to do
um these charts are always from uh our
raptor metrics was which is a pretty
common metric used in uh basketball and
we can see you know we have our raptor
stuff and we see like a player
evaluation or with their raptor scores
uh in this case it's steph curry so yeah
this is a pretty accurate is completely
accurate uh scene and we're still doing
it today
our next movie is the imitation game
yes
why do you think your german counterpart
has a girlfriend it's just a stupid joke
don't worry no no no tell me
well each of his messages begins with
the same five letters c-i-l-l-y
so i suspect that silly must be the name
of fizzmore it's impossible that james
are instructed to use five random
letters at the start of every message
well this doesn't
love will make a man do strange things i
suppose
in this case
i've just lost germany the whole bloody
war
so in this scene they talk about
basically uh doing some pattern
recognition um
as for data scientists we don't really
do a lot like cryptography but what
they're talking about is using um these
uh finding patterns or essentially a
shared word
across all these documents and it really
reminded me of using uh a common
weighing scheme with text text data
called tf idf uh which is called the
term frequency by inverse document
frequency and this uh i guess like
algorithm or a weighting scheme uh it
measures how often a a word is said and
how rare it is between all of the groups
this is very good for like machine
learning when we're trying to find words
that can kind of separate and be highly
predictive uh for for our classes but
it's also able to find hey what are the
words that are used by all the groups
and stuff like this is a very simple
algorithm and
it's very useful in your day-to-day
basis
but again i don't do a lot of
cryptography i don't think a lot of data
scientists do a lot of cryptography i
think it's more of a mathematician type
of thing but it kind of reminds you of
this algorithm for this waiting scheme
and i just like to share that uh
metric
so our next scene or our next movie is
margin call
peter is this your work
mostly mr dale's
but is this your draft
yes um
again expanded on the original work by
mr dale but yes
what's your background my background
your cv i've been with the firm for two
and a half years working with eric that
whole time but i hold a doctorate in
engineering specialty and propulsion
from mit with the bachelor's from penn
what is a specialty in propulsion
exactly my thesis was studying the ways
that friction ratios affect steering
outcomes and aeronautical use under
reduced gravity loads
so you're a rocket scientist
i was
yeah
interesting
how did you end up here it's all just
numbers really just changing what you're
adding up and to speak freely
the money here is considerably more
attractive
oops so in this scene they're talking
about a quant
who's working at an investment firm and
with an engineering background and the
reason why i wanted to show this scene
is this is actually very common in data
science
most data scientists don't have data
science degrees
they come from various backgrounds in
fact it's actually pretty common to see
people with uh phds in psychology pivot
into like a data science tech career
because for one thing psychology is an
extremely crowded field and the seller
isn't great so
people do a lot of pivoting to data
science from like engineering economics
stats psychology chemistry biology
backgrounds like pharmaceutical
backgrounds and stuff like that
and it's something to always kind of
keep in mind because most data science
techniques is just statistics which are
found in other industries they might be
named a few a little bit differently but
um it's very easy to pivot from um
from
other industries as long as you are good
at like looking at data manipulating
data in a programmatic way and that's
replicable um you can become a data
scientist very easily from just pivoting
okay next scene is minority report
let's not kid ourselves we are arresting
individuals who have broken no law but
they will the commission of the crime
itself is absolute metaphysics the
pre-conquest see the future and they're
never wrong but it's not the future if
you stop it
isn't that a fundamental paradox
yes it is
you're talking about pre-determination
which happens all the time
why'd you catch that because it was
gonna fall
you're certain yeah
but it didn't fall
you caught it
the fact that you prevented it from
happening doesn't change the fact that
it was going to happen you ever get any
false positives
someone intends to kill his boss or his
wife but they never go through with it
how do the precogs tell the difference
precognition to see what you intend to
do
only what you will do
so in this scene they're talking about
basically this oracle or thing that
makes predictions on like murders um and
they're talking about hey what happens
if we falsely convict someone or falsely
uh predict that someone is gonna murder
someone and just uh arrest them before
they actually do it were they actually
going to make the murder
um and this is actually a common thing
not with predicting murders but it's a
common thing about how we assess models
and their accuracy when we're making
predictions on whether someone's going
to do something or not so like with the
binary outcome
in this specific case uh this is this is
actually a very interesting problem with
uh classification models uh when we're
dealing with imbalanced data sets where
you know our positive outcome is very
small so in this case a positive outcome
or a positive prediction
is a murder um generally people don't
get murdered right so the class and
balance is very high
in fact our conventional way of
protecting accuracy is you know our
predicted murders and predicted
non-murders over the total sample will
be highly skewed because we just say no
one's going to murder each other and get
like a 99.99
accuracy
luckily we actually have different
metrics
to assess this
as you can see right here
this is a confusion matrix and it's
showing basically all of the metrics
that we kind of create or conventional
metrics that we use
to assess our model's predictions at the
end of the day it's just doing some
adding and subtraction and a little bit
of multiplication but we can see that
how we can use these true positives
false positives false tags and true
negatives
and do a little bit different arithmetic
to get
different assessments of our model
thing that they're also talking about is
when we make predictions on outcomes
that have not happened
uh that's actually called like sensor
data it's often used in survival
analysis so we're trying to predict you
know if someone has cancer um what's the
you know survival rate for them to uh to
survive cancer uh through time
and oftentimes we have people who
haven't died yet so we're trying to
model them out so that's a common thing
that we use in survivor analysis um
one thing that we use is also like
precision and recall uh
and that's a pretty good metric to use
so we have precision right here and we
also have a recall right here
and we often use what we have in
balanced data sets is a roc curve
which is the
percentage or the comparison of the true
positive rate with a false positive rate
and also we use precision recall curves
which is you know uh the relationship
between precision and recall given a
specific probability and
we can use these as basically a better
assessment of like imbalanced uh classes
great so our last movie is going to be
the social network
perfect timing eduardo is here and he's
going to have the key ingredient hey
mark eduardo your america split up
how did you know that it's on your blog
yeah are you all right i need you i'm
here for you
now i need the algorithm used during
chess players are you okay
we're ranking girls
you mean other students yeah do you
think this is such a good idea i need
the algorithm all right i need the
algorithm
give each girl a base rating of 1400 at
any given time girl a has a rating our
angle b has a rating rb when any two
girls are matched up there's an
expectation of which will win based on
her current rating right yeah and those
expectations are expressed this way
let's write it
so in this scene they're basically
creating face mash which is a uh a site
that compares uh women
and ranks them uh i love this scene
because it kind of shows the uh the
double-edged sword of data science as a
whole um and also kind of the beauties
of data science so
the algorithm that they use is a basic
elo algorithm it's used a lot obviously
in chess with it which they mentioned
it's also used in video games and sports
and it's a good ranking algorithm
because we have these head-to-head
matchups
and we can basically gain and lose
points uh using this algorithm
it's a good way to rank them
but why i talk about the double edged
sword is that yes it's beautiful that we
can use these very simple algorithms
that are used like uh in the 1800s
but also we can see how even though we
can use these very uh elegant algorithms
it can cause a lot of harm to people uh
in this case it's a very uh kind of
gross way of using algorithm by having
these um ranking of women it's not it's
not very good but
uh it's something that we kind of have
to consider again data scientists uh
need to kind of figure out like yes
it's we do a lot of work with data we
think about like models and ways to
manipulate data but there's also a thing
where we kind of have to think about the
ethics of data and to me this is a
perfect summarization of modern data
science you know we're trying to use
these algorithms to create these
products but sometimes these products
can harm people um and it's very uh
compelling that's this is also facebook
which has their own issues and stuff
like that but
i also want to say is um when we're
using um when we're thinking about using
tools from our toolbar for a data
scientist uh in general we will actually
want to use a very simple model simple
models are preferable and i think elo is
kind of a good algorithm because it's
very simple and it's very elegant and
it's very useful for our own problem
um i hope you guys like this video um i
had a lot of fun making this but i'll
see you guys next time and uh tidy on